today let's show you 11 signs of certain
deficiencies in your body these are
pretty common and I think it's a good
idea to be able to understand various
things that go on in your body and
what's really behind them from a
nutritional standpoint so the first one
is excessive yawning okay
oh man like that now it could be you're
tired it could be you're out of shape
but more likely it is an iron deficiency
if you're low on iron you can't make
heme in your blood and you're going to
be a bit deficient in oxygen and you're
going to want to try to get more air so
either the person is not consuming
enough iron from their diet because
maybe they're a vegan or the stomach
acid and their stomach is not strong
enough to be able to extract this iron
from the meat that they eat but
typically the best source of iron is in
red meat now this symptom also relates
to the next one which is air hunger like
you have difficulty breathing a little
different but similar this too is a
situation where you're trying to get
more oxygen but usually the cause is
because your body or more specifically
your blood is too acidic okay slightly
too acidic normally the blood should be
slightly alkaline and so if the pH goes
down just a little bit too much you're
considered having something called
acidosis and that symptom usually comes
from a B1 deficiency so when you're
deficient in B1 the little energy
factors in your cells called the
mitochondria don't work that well
because when you think about B1 think of
it as like a spark plug to ignite the
oxygen fuel carburetor in your
mitochondria just like an engine and so
without that spark plug we can't burn
fuel and then things can kind of backed
up and you start developing too much
lactic acid and that produces a lack of
oxygen and all you need to do is take B1
but also realize they're the number one
reason why people are deficient in B1 is
that they're eating too many carbs and
sugars so the more carbs you eat the
more B1 you're going to need to deal
with those carbs thus we recommend going
on keto all right the next symptom would
be this little tetany a little pitching
it could be on the eyelid or in the face
or in the arm what is that that is just
the opposite your blood is excessively
alkaline okay and when your blood is
successfully alkaline you can't
transport calcium that well so calcium
starts building up on the nerves and
they short-circuit the nerve
conductivity creating kind of like a a
twitching going on at the muscle itself
so we have this interference between the
nerve and the muscle causing this tetany
and so whether this alkaline situation
is causing it or just one of the
symptoms of it you don't really know
based on just tetany but a simple remedy
would be to take some apple cider
vinegar to kind of acidify the body a
bit and mobilize that calcium another
remedy to actually increase more
absorption of this calcium could be to
take just vitamin D that could be the
reason but in this situation
calcium is kind of stuck in the body so
you can have symptoms of a Calcium
deficiency it's not really Calcium
deficiency it's just kind of locked up
so we need to mobilize it by altering
the pH as well as taking vitamin D
another thing you can kind of identify
certain deficiencies is looking at the
stool
now if your stool is green
typically it's because you're not
digesting your salad or your greens and
that chlorophyll is showing up down in
your stool
now yes it's true that chlorophyll is
fat soluble and you could be deficient
in bile but more than likely it's not
that that's causing it it's usually
socially with diarrhea and something
going on in the gut whether you have
some type of Mal absorption in the
digestive system because maybe you had
some damage or inflammation there so if
you find that as soon as you start
increasing your vegetables you get
diarrhea and you have green stool then
you should probably just avoid
vegetables for now and do the carnivore
diet for a while because your system is
not able to digest it and it could be
also related to a lack of friendly
bacteria now if the stool is yellowish
or pale
uh think lack of bile because you're
having too much fat especially if the
stool floats that means you need more
bile so you can take that as a
supplement even though bile is not a
nutrient it is an essential thing to
help you extract fats part of bile is
something called bilirubin it's it's
like the byproduct of red blood cells
that are damaged or broken that your
body has to kind of deal with them so it
then it turns into bilirubin which uh
the Latin word for that is red as in the
color in your blood but when it breaks
down it kind of goes through the blood
and the urine and then also in the bile
ducts in the bowel and so when it
oxidizes a certain type of chemical
reactions that cause different coloring
effects from this bilirubin so this is
why your urine is yellow and this is why
your stool should be brown it's actually
originally coming from that red orange
pigment but if the stool is light
colored or pale that means or yellow
that means that you're lacking bile so
there's something going on with the
gallbladder another common symptom is
achiness in your lower back or your hips
or even the upper part of your legs that
is a classic vitamin D deficiency okay
and I would take probably 10 000 I use
and within probably
10 15 minutes you're going to feel your
back a lot better a lack of vitamin D
will also cause like bone pain so if you
press like on your sternum right here
your breastbone and it's sore that's a
good indication that you need more
vitamin D you can also press on your
shins the front part of your lower leg
bone and if it's sore chances are you
need more vitamin D next uh symptom
would be cold intolerance you cannot
tolerate the cold that is an iodine
deficiency because it's a function of
the thyroid and as an extra little thing
if you can't tolerate heat typically
that could be also a B1 deficiency and
also sometimes this cold intolerance
could be a B1 deficiency too but more
than likely it's going to be an iodine
deficiency which a lot of people are
deficient in all right now what about a
white tongue that is candida overgrowth
in your colon you have a lot of bacteria
like 99 bacteria and then you have one
percent other microorganisms like yeast
fungus and also candida and normally
they exist in a friendly state but as
soon as you stress these microorganisms
out usually by taking an antibiotic
and you kill off the bacteria but it
doesn't kill off other things like yeast
then you eliminate that thing that keeps
this candida in check
so now we get an overgrowth of candida
and at the same time they become a bit
unfriendly so they create problems in
your body and they start to Rob
nutrition and create all sorts of issues
so you'll see this overgrowth of candida
on your mouth
so the real cause is a deficiency of
probiotics so you just need to take a
probiotic but the other thing is that if
you continue to eat sugar or any type of
refined carbohydrate you'll keep feeding
them so you have to give up sugar to
kill them off because they only can live
on sugar they don't eat fats they don't
eat proteins so as soon as you starve
them they go away let's say you had high
LDL and low HDL that is a classic
vitamin B3 deficiency it's called niacin
if you were going to take this as a
remedy which by the way is a really
potent
um regulator of cholesterol and
triglycerides in LDL and as well as to
help regulate HDL make sure you take the
type of B3 that is the niacin not the
one that doesn't create a flush you want
the B3 that creates the flushing or else
it won't work all right the next sign
would be bloating or stomach pain
or indigestion that is a classic lack of
acid in your stomach and the remedy is
betaine hydrochloride that means that
your stomach does not have enough acid
to digest your food all right next
symptom would be muscle weakness that is
a classic sodium deficiency okay you
need more salt and last one is high
blood pressure
and we can also include in their high
pulse rate
if you have that that means that you
need more potassium it's a potassium
deficiency and sometimes a vitamin D
deficiency this is why sometimes when
people take vitamin D they may even end
up with low blood pressure or a low
pulse rate most people need Vitamin D
and it helps to regulate the
cardiovascular system very very
efficiently so now that you understand
how to read the body a little bit better
if you haven't seen this very popular
video on how to evaluate your liver
based on your foot I put that video
right here